nous sommes dans le quartier notre dame
à proximité de la fonderie horne une
récente étude ici a démontré que les
enfants du quartier ont quatre fois plus
d'arsenic dans le corps en moyenne
qu'ailleurs au québec 'l'indice du
cancer du poumon à rouyn noranda est
aussi significativement plus élevés
c'est dans ce contexte que glencore
propriétaire de l'entreprise négocier
avec le gouvernement afin de diminuer
ses émissions d'arsenic notamment la
fonderie propose une moyenne annuelle de
60 nanogrammes par mètre cube la norme
québécoise elle est de 3 c'est donc 20
fois la norme québécoise cette mère de
famille n'en reviens pas c'est qu'il
devrait pas y avoir de négociations ça
devrait être le gouvernement qui fixe le
chiffre qui fait que les échéances et
puis l'entreprise doit se conformer un
point c'est tout là on a l'impression
qu'on achète du temps les citoyens sont
impatients sont inquiets la situation
est elle est urgente
c'est difficile de présumer de la bonne
foi d'une entreprise qui agit comme ça
ce médecin de famille à rouyn noranda
estime pour sa part qu'il ne s'agit même
pas d'une base de négociation pour
vraiment qu'on est beaucoup plus loin
que sol on le sait on paye le pro du
passé au niveau de notre santé c'est un
pan des bonnes décisions pour le futur
en 2021 la fonderie on a émis en moyenne
87 nanogrammes par mètre cube lors de
négociations avec le gouvernement
charest en 2006 l'entreprise assurait
pouvoir atteindre 39 nanogrammes par
mètre cube à condition d'investir 120
millions de dollars mais québec avait
par la suite reculé devant les pressions
d'entreprise et fixer la limite à 200
nano grammes quelle entreprise propose
quelque chose de plus haut qu'à l'aide
et je propose
presque irréelle
les gouvernements qui se sont succédé
ont fait preuve de laxisme se sont
couchés devant l'entreprise oui c'est un
rendez vous en rendez vous ratés mais la
réalité c'est que l'information n'était
pas disponible comme elle l'est depuis
2010 8 et 7 avant cette information-là
aurait dû pousser le gouvernement à agir
en fin de journée la fonderie ion et
nous a fait savoir vouloir diminuer ses
émissions le plus rapidement possible et
qu'un plan plus ambitieux sera présenté
au cours des prochaines semaines
au cabinet du premier ministre françois
legault
menace toujours l'entreprise de
fermeture s'il est incapable de
s'approcher de la norme québécoise et si
jean-marc bédier radio canada rouyn
noranda